اسرار القدس اعلنت
عن الشخصيه التي تم استهدافها اليوم وتاخر
الاعلان عن هويه الشخص المستهدف
نعم بالتاكيد اعلنت سرايا القدس ان
الحسني وهو من اكبر قيادات سرايا القدس هو
المستهدف وقد تم بالفعل اغتياله من قبل
الطائرات الاسرائيليه
واكدت سرايا القدس ان استمرار اغتيال
هؤلاء القاده لن يضعف المقاومه وان الرد
سيكون على استمرار سياسه الاغتيالات برد
المقاومه واستمرار اطلاق الصواريخ في
العمق الاسرائيلي
وكما كانت قد حذرت ايضا المقاومه من
استمرار توسيع
الجيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من غاراته ومن
استهدافاته على قطاع غزه وخاصه استهداف
المنازل واستمرار سياسه الاغتيالات وفي
هذا الخصوص كانت ق الاحتلال الاسرائيليه
وجيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي قد كثف بالفعل
غاراته منذ عصر هذا اليوم وحتى الساعه
الاخيره استمرت هذه الغارات مستهدفه ايضا
المنازل تم قصف عدد من المنازل في الساعات
الاخيره اخر هذه الغارات كان في دير البلح
استهدف منزلا مكون من عده طوابق وايضا
بنايه سكنيه في حي الزيتون جنوب شرق مدينه
غزه وايضا كان هناك استهداف سابق لعدد من
البنايات والمنازل في جباليا وفي بيت
لاهيا في رفح وفي خان يونس وفي دير البلح
وسط قطاع غزه وبالتالي جميع مناطق قطاع
غزه كانت قد تعرضت هذا اليوم لغارات من
الطائرات الاسرائيليه باستهداف المنازل
كما ذكرنا والبنايات السك وايضا اراضي
زراعيه ومناطق فارغه والاستهداف الاكبر
كان في حي النصر شمال غرب مدينه غزه
باستهداف الشقه السكنيه التي اغتيل فيها
القائد في سرايا القدس الحسني
والذي نعته
سرايا القدس في بيان لها بعد ساعات من
اغتياله وكان التساؤل عن تاخير اعلان
الاسم وكما ذكر زميلنا وائل الدحدوح الذي
كان في المكان وكما ذكر شهود عيان فقد تم
اخراج جثامين الشهيد جثماني الشهيدين وهم
في حاله صعبه جدا اي انهم كانوا اشلاء
ومتفحمه وقد اقتضى الامر كما يعتقد الجميع
بعض الوقت للتاكيد ولان يكون الامر قد بت
فيه بشكل نهائي ولكن هذا
ريال هو كان الاغتيال السادس
للقيادات لقيادات من سرايا القدس الجناح
العسكري لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي خلال اربعه
ايام وقد كانت الضربه الاولى لهذه العمليه
العسكريه والتي بدات فيها هذا التصعيد
العسكري باغتيال ثلاثه من اكبر ايضا
قيادات سرايا القدس في قطاع غزه واحدهم
كان مسؤول عن العمليات في الضفه الغربيه
وبذلك
استمرت هذه العمليه ولكن استمرار هذه
العمليه كان في المقابل له رد من قبل
فصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه التي واصلت
اطلاق زخات ورشقات من الصواريخ طوال هذه
الايام وحتى الساعات الاخيره كانت هناك
رشاقات واكدت على الفصائل الفلسطينيه